folks it's that time of year when the
Grammy nominations are announced and I
thought I'd try something a little
different and make a video like this
just giving you guys my thoughts to the
extent you might be interested usually I
just tweet out some stuff about this but
I figured you know I have a YouTube
channel so maybe I should use it I think
you guys should all know how I feel
about the Grammys uh I'll remind you
just for the one time real quick the
Grammys are racist uh I've been saying
this many times I'm not a hero for
saying it I'm not trying to get points
or something uh reason I remind you
especially when the nominations come out
is that every year there are great
nominations and then almost always the
winners are to be expected along the
lines of you know the Grammys just
picking what kind of made the most money
and without respect for artists who
aren't white for the most part so I I
tell you that just to temper
expectations here but just like
everybody else you know I get excited
about these nominations I I looked at
the list and saw some cool names so I'm
just going to kind of go over them with
you and I will give you not just my
hopes my prediction of like who I would
like to see win but more realistic the
prediction of who I think is going to
win and I think you're going to see a
theme throughout this video uh something
along the lines of Taylor Swift but
anyway let's just let's just see what
we' got here and go through I'll just go
through the categories where I've heard
most if not all the things so record of
the year uh if you didn't know the
difference between record of the year
and song of the Year song is more so
about the songwriting record is more
about the production and in my opinion
kind of like the splash that the song
made so looking at these ones uh I think
truly I think Kill Bill is a serious
Contender I that's one of my least
favorite songs from sz's album but that
one's been huge that Miley Cyrus song
flowers has also been huge uh Billy ish
what was I made for I feel like that
one's pretty big too I think all of
those are great songs boy Genius not
strong enough that's crazy I I I think
it's so cool that boy Genius is
nominated for Grammys I love that song
that's probably my favorite of all the
songs listed here uh so if you know in a
perfect world I would want that one to
win but I don't really think it's got a
shot at record of the year I more
realistically I mean come on if Taylor
Swift is in the category we can just say
Taylor Swift is going to win I hate to
say it but and I I like Anti Hero that's
one of my favorite songs from that album
uh most likely that's what is going to
win I wouldn't be shocked if um
something like Kill Bill or flowers won
I guess I would be shocked because
Taylor Swift exists but uh those would
probably be the top three choices
there uh album of the Year again boy
Genius the fact that they're in here is
insane that's a great great project uh
Janelle Mones wasn't a huge fan it was
good uh John batist I've not heard that
of course he's nominated again after
they gave it to him last year Lana Del
re okay listen that album is one of my
favorites of the year that's like my
number two and Lord knows scaring the
hose is not going to get nominated here
so my front runner pick in my heart has
got to go to Lad for this album it's
fantastic it's maybe her best ever it's
like right up there with Born to Die for
me so super stoked to see that here
Miley was pretty good Olivia Rodrigo is
pretty good sz's SOS another fantastic
album um again not my favorite over Lana
and then of course Taylor Swift listen I
I saw that if Taylor Swift wins album of
the Year here she'll have won it four
times which is maybe or probably a
record listen you can't bet against
Taylor Swift she uh is white and also
the Grammys love her so I wouldn't be
surprised Midnight's is probably going
to win this I'm just letting you
know song of the year so again this is
more about the songwriting aspect uh
interesting differences here to put the
do a leap a dance song in here for
songwriting you know lad Del R A&W that
is just truly insane I never thought I'd
see the day that um like do the people
at the Grammys know that A&W stands for
American I'm not sure uh to me
easily easily that one has to win out of
this category I think it's a fantastic
song really powerful songw writing from
Lana it it should win but once again we
uh Taylor Swift exists and we'll
probably win this um these other ones
like again kill build not one of my
favorites from SOS and uh uh songwriting
is fine but that's one of the songs one
of the songs where she's the most
obsessed with her ex and I just it it's
troubling to me that that album that's
my biggest gripe with the album is
there's a lot of a lot of X Obsession
and that one I feel like that's part of
the reason why I don't like that song as
much but flowers is great I feel like
it'd be weird to give her songwriting
because it's just kind of a riff on that
Bruno Mars song uh Olivia Rodriguez is
fine I vampire to me was one of the
weaker tracks on that project it felt
very much like they were going for a
driver's license 2.0 and I think
driver's license is better songwriting
but again I don't even know why I'm
wasting time talking about this when
Taylor Swift is going to win but my top
two would probably be Lana Del Rey or
Billy ish honestly what was I made for
is a really good one Best New Artist
there's no point wasting time on this
it's going to go to ice spice okay it's
just not it like it wouldn't make sense
for any other artist to get it her
momentum has been too it it's like
frightening I mean she had a song with
Again Taylor Swift this is the Grammy's
favorite person so it's going to go to
her with almost 100% certainty that's my
prediction U I don't like I don't know
many of these names on here I definitely
know Victoria Monae she's great I I
don't think she's going to win I've
heard people saying no kahan's the one
to beat but ice spice exists and Taylor
Swift exists and they work together so I
just I'd be shocked if it didn't go to
her produc of the year non-classical
it's cool to see Metro boomman I wonder
if this is his it's probably his first
nomination in this category so great to
see that and hit boy too Jack antinoff
is in this category just about every
year and I I feel like he'd probably win
again he he produced most of that lanto
Del Ray album and because I love that so
much I wouldn't be upset if he won here
either Metro boomman would be a cool
pick to see uh but yeah it's probably
going to be Jack pop solo performance
interesting we got doic cat with paint
the town red not one of my favorites
from that album but it's a good song uh
Miley Cyrus for flowers I feel like as
far as Pop performance she puts her
heart into that one so that's a good
performance so was Billy ishes what was
I made for those would probably be my
top two
here again it's Taylor Swift's category
to win because she's Taylor Swift and
just so we're clear guys I like Taylor
Swift she she got some great songs she
got some great music I do like antie her
I think it's a great song I just it it's
tiring to see one person win all these
Awards over and over again like the
Grammys have the capability to boost
artists who maybe don't have the
spotlight on them as much and you know
it's huge for people's career to be able
to say they were nominated or especially
to have won a Grammy Taylor Swift
doesn't need that she does not need the
accolades she is one of the biggest
artists in the world we saw that with
her eras tour that's still going in the
movie it's just there it seems silly to
keep tacking medals on to uniform
because it's already full
um it just doesn't make sense but so
she's probably going to win but if we're
talking performance I personally would
probably lean toward Miley Cyrus I think
she's got a great voice and she really
belts it out on that track so pop duo or
group performance cool to see candy
necklace from that Lana album um there
were better Duo ones on there I think uh
the track with Jack anof for bleachers
that one's probably my favorite for the
Duos and then of course you have the one
with the Father John Misty but John
batist he won album of the year last
year so he's somebody that's going to be
in their Graces if if you guys didn't
realize this um there's a lot of
campaigning that goes on behind the
scenes and a lot of these names it's
like you'll see them over and over when
it comes to the grammies uh Brandy
Carlile you can see on the next track
right here she's a name that's always in
there uh her is always in there too John
Batista I think is becoming one of those
artists as well so don't be shocked I
don't even remember this song with
Brandy Carlile unfort fortunately uh Siz
and Phoebe Bridges goes to the machine
really enjoyed that song that's a cool
one it's not the most organic pairing if
I'm being honest um it's cool I love
both artists it just didn't feel like
they had that much chemistry and then
Taylor Swift and Ice spice I'll be
honest I've not heard the remix I heard
Karma I don't know if I've even heard
the remix I've heard that the chemistry
is not there and that it feels very much
like let's just get the most popular new
artist on Taylor Swift song then again
we're talking about Taylor Swift who has
won a bajillion Grammys and Ice spice
who's nominated for Best New Artist I
feel like it's most likely going to win
my favorite song here would probably be
ghost in the machine but I don't think
it's going to beat out Karma so there's
that for you pop vocal album Ed Sheeran
subtract uh boy I I feel like I listened
to that album I can't remember Ed
Sheeran just kind of whizzes by me when
I listen to his music Miley Cyrus that
was a good album I did not hear the
Kelly Clarkson I Rodrigo's guts was good
Taylor Swift midnights listen I don't
need to when Taylor Swift is in the
category she's going to win uh my
favorite album here ah honestly it
probably is midnights so uh yeah I'm
going to go with that best rock
performance again very cool to see boy
genius I don't really know that it's not
exactly a rock song again rock song not
strong enough it's not really a rock
song I I really love that song it's my
favorite on the album uh Olivia
Rodrigo's ballot of a homeschooled girl
I can't remember if that was one of the
tracks I liked again seems odd to be
giving those artists rock song nods I
think boy Genius is more along the lines
of alternative Indie type stuff and
Olivia Rodrigo I know she's going more
towards like the pop punk side of things
but I I feel like her music is still pop
music at least that's how it it sorted
in my mind so alternative music
performance listen always nominated for
Belinda says that is an amazing song one
of my favorites from that album I would
love to see that one that's such a great
song cool about it from boy genius I
can't remember which song that is um but
that's a great album there's a lot of
good songs it's probably a good one uh
interesting that they'd pick that when
not strong enough is all over here but
and of course Lana Del re with A&W
that's another huge song Personally I'm
going to say I'd love to see it go to
always cuzz I don't see them in any
other C categories here I'd love to see
always get a Grammy they're such a great
band I love them I think ladel Ray is
probably most likely to win this just
because A&W is nominated in some of the
bigger top song categories so that would
be my prediction alternative music album
again Lana most likely to win this
because of the fact that she's in album
of the year that's kind of how these
things go but yeah Lana's probably going
to win and she would be my pick cuz I
love that one R&B
performance again I want to see siza win
a million Grammys I love is it kill Bill
is not it's one of my least favorite
songs on the album like I would loved to
see far get nominated here that's a
great performance I don't think the
performance on Kill Bill is even that
impressive compared to a lot of the
other tracks on there but most likely to
win because of the fact that that's in
song of the year and all that see here
you go traditional R&B performance we
have a difference as a song that's love
language which is a great song that's I
like that one more than Kill Bill for
sure this distinction between R&B and
traditional R&B is kind of strange just
like let's pick a different sza song and
then here we go best R&B song we have
another one with snooze now I do snooze
is a great song definitely love that one
more than Kill Bill on my mama was
really good too that would be cool to
see that one but siza is so big at this
point that I would be shocked if anybody
else won this category and yeah
Progressive R&B album I'm not entirely
sure what that means but sis is probably
going to win that with SOS that's the
biggest one here and it's my favorite
here too so I would have no issue with
that R&B album I don't I don't quite
understand the distinction between these
categories but at least they are five
different albums otherwise it wouldn't
make any sense uh I'm personally going
to go with v Victoria Monet I haven't
heard all of these but I really liked
her project if you haven't listened to
her go check out some of her stuff now
here we go rap performance I'm going be
more familiar with the rap stuff so BBE
ke and Kendrick for Hillbillies it's
kind of crazy that's cool to see uh
Black Thought obviously always good coy
race players uh I actually don't mind
that song but weird to have that in the
rap performance category uh Rich Flex I
do like Rich Flex that's one of the
songs I really enjoyed from that album I
do like Rich Flex hey guys jumping in
here quick editor's note uh Rich Flex is
not one of the songs that I like from
this album I just went back and played
it realized that is the 21 can you do
some for me I no not a fan of that song
I think I was thinking of privileged
rappers or maybe broke boys both of
which are a lot better look there are
some great songs on that album but yeah
Rich Flex is not one of them sorry kind
of weird to have it in rap performance
and then the Killer Mike track with
three stacks future scientists and
Engineers that was a great song that was
one of my favorites on that album too I
don't know I I think I mean Kendrick is
a name that means a lot to the Grammys
so I wouldn't be surprised if
Hillbilly's one I feel like it's
probably between that and Rich Flex cuz
just this the sheer size of those
artists Kendrick and Drake I don't think
Rich Flex is a very impressive
performance I do think Hillbillies is
better along the lines of rap
performance again the difference between
rap song and rap performance performance
I think is going to be more about like
the flow and the energy whereas rap song
is more focused on the writing
Hillbillies brought a great performance
out of those two guys they this is a
track where everybody likes to demean it
saying oh they were just having fun it
doesn't really matter and I wasn't a big
fan of the song personally but I think
it definitely fits in this category more
so than like kiler race players there's
not a lot of not a whole lot of
performative effort that went into that
it's a good song though actually I'm
going to change my answer I'm going to
say it's either going to be Hillbillies
or players cuz players K Ray is kind of
that was a huge song melodic rap
performance let's see here I'm not sure
if I know the burnaboy song I'm not a
big fan of little Dirk that one didn't
do much for me sis is low that's another
one of my least favorite on the album
it's cool to see though now I think it's
like four or five songs from that one
album have been nominated in various
categories that's kind of feel good but
I don't like that one that much spin
about you is a fun track spin about you
is again one of my favorites from they
kind of pick these songs right I do like
Rich
Flex one of my favorites from her loss
that would be my personal pick here
though honestly Dojo cat's attention is
really good too one of my favorites on
that project that those would be my two
top two picks his attention it's beenin
about you but given the fact that SZ is
in so many categories I wouldn't be
shocked if she won this too but again I
I can't in good faith vote for a song
that I didn't really like best rap song
Too cat's attention Rich Flex is back
from her loss that's
cool the Killer Mike and three stacks
song just want a rock by luzi vert hell
yes I want to hear somebody scream damn
for like 30 seconds on stage and then
Barbie world oh man I I do not like the
original Barbie world song and I also
don't like the the sort of play on it
that they did here it just G it's not it
is not interesting to me at all I would
be devastated if that one I would love
if Uzi won this it's not really as far
as you know writing goes it's not that
impressive but your writing standpoint I
think Killer Mike and three stack should
win I think it's more likely going to be
dojat or Drake in 21 my Dark Horse pick
would be just want to rock cuz I that
song is hilarious best rap album okay
her loss I did I liked her loss there I
my version of it that I listened to was
maybe eight songs um but it wasn't super
bloated I wouldn't mind that winning
killer Mike's Michael very cool to see
him get nominated I didn't love that
project there were some great songs on
it though Petro rumman heroes and
villains great songs on that one too
again not one that I loved that one's
been pretty successful a lot of people
like it King's disease 3 I think I
listened to this one I am losing track
of the Kings disease albums at this
point and that's not fair but uh it's
Nas Nas is crazy and I think he's been
nominated for all three kings disease
albums at this this point which is
really cool and he's Nots so I know it's
good again I've listened to probably two
of the three I can't remember which one
I didn't listen to absolutely deserving
of the inclusion here I don't know if it
will win but cool to see always and
Travis Scott with Utopia no surprise
there big artist I wouldn't be shocked
if they gave it to him to kind of make
up for Astro World not winning but I
personally don't like Utopia as much as
his other projects my favorite on this
list o I don't know that's a tough one
it would maybe be between Utopia and her
loss I think they both have issues um
truthfully King's disease is probably
the best on here to me killer Mark
Michael is also really good too it's not
a bad category um but this is a good
point this is a good point to bring up
the fact that there were no hip-hop
albums in the best album category which
it happens quite a bit um not really
surprising again we know the Grammys are
racist so they don't they don't really
understand hip-hop my favorite rap album
that probably fits within this
time frame is scaring the hose there's
no way scaring the hose is going to get
nominated so I'm not even surprised that
it's not here I think Utopia is probably
the one to beat I would personally pick
that as my favorite over her loss it's
very slightly ahead for me would be very
cool to see Nas win or any of these guys
really Nas Metro boomman Killer Mike
that would each of those would be really
cool but I think it's probably going to
be Travis Scott that's my guess a what
you
want yeah I have not listened to much
country music this year country song I I
did see there was a little bit of
controversy not controversy but people
were making fun of the fact that Morgan
wallan is one of the biggest artists
right now in terms of numbers because
his album was number one for the longest
time and last night was a very big song
I do know that one but he didn't write
it so technically he wouldn't get the
crammy here and dude is also a problem
um you guys can look that up if you're
interested I would love to see a guy
like that get shut out cuz he thinks
he's he thinks he's hot and I I
don't know I don't think he's that
impressive very very poppy kind of bro
country stuff to me I know Chris
Stapleton and Tyle Tyler Childers are
better artists I've definitely heard
their music Zack Bryan's pretty good
Casey Musgraves um seems like it's going
to be all similar names for Country
album Kelsey ballerini is pretty good
too again I I don't think I listen to
any of these albums though so no comment
for me these could be more interesting
so compilation soundtrack for visual
media I don't know what Aurora is Barbie
the album black panther album Gardens of
the Galaxy 3 and Weird Al I I don't know
all of these it's almost certainly going
to the Barbie album there's too many
nominations in here for Barbie songs for
that not to win I'd be shocked genuinely
shocked best score okay we got fabl
men's that was a good one Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny I didn't see but
those are both John Williams so you know
they're good John Williams is a goat
Black Panthers score oppenheimer's
easily my pick uh that's cool and
interesting that John Williams and
Ludwig are both nominated for two
separate movies but Oppenheimer is such
a good score and Barbie the soundtrack
is great but the score was not memorable
to me I feel like they might be feeling
a little Barbie fever over there at the
Grammys so maybe they' give it to it but
I think Oppenheimer deserves that one
for sure song for visual media okay this
is this is a cool one we got Ryan
Gosling nominated for a Grammy that's
got to be the first time for him right
Gosling is actually a bit of a musician
if you guys didn't know he had a band um
I'm blanking on the name of it Dead
Man's Bones I think is what it was they
made kind of a Halloween type of album I
actually have it it's really good and
there's a song from that featured in The
Conjuring just a weird piece of trivia
to know about Ryan
Gosling something but yeah the Ken song
from the movie that one's cool I who
were they saying who wrote it it might
have been Mark Ronson or somebody but I
remember some trivia saying it was like
sent to the movie as a joke and when
Ryan goling was like no I definitely
need to do this and here now it's
nominated for Grammy so that's really
cool Rihanna's lift me up I it didn't do
much for me I understand the the impact
that might have had especially in the
movie but songwriting wasn't it wasn't
that spectacular either uh Barbie world
please God no thank you uh do Lia again
so we got three songs from Barbie DM uh
I would say I would say oh wait no four
cuz again good Lord uh I would
personally give it to Billy eish for
what was that made for that's a really
good song it'd be very cool if Ryan
Gosling one too though that'd be a fun
Dark Horse pick so yeah I think that is
going to be it so that's my thoughts on
the Grammys again folks uh like I said
I've said it before I'll say it on other
videos surely the Grammys are racist we
know this um I just want to remind you
guys to temper your expectations right
Curb Your Enthusiasm if you will because
uh the nominations usually have a lot of
cool artists and they end up going to
the most predictable boring picks which
again I like Taylor Swift I liked
midnights and anti-heroes all over the
place that's actually one of the songs I
did enjoy from there but she's just
going to win because she's Taylor Swift
so it's kind of like we can just we can
skip the show this year and just like
send them to her via UPS just not waste
everybody's time that'd be my prediction
if if it does not go that way I would be
very happy to be wrong about this thank
you guys for watching I hope this was at
least mildly interesting maybe killed
some time for you uh if you're
interested in this kind of commentary
type of video this is pretty easy so
maybe I'll find some more opportunities
to do this if this one does well but
yeah I'll see you guys on the next video